good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Friday Friday
got to get down on Friday why are you
singing like that cuz I'm so Overjoyed
excited and feeling blessed that today
is Friday and I can't feel my ears why
cuz they're being pulled back so tight
in this bun that's like not a descriptor
of a bun I thought maybe you're cold you
can't feel your ears but we need to talk
about the bun no I cannot feel like my
scalp like it's just like uh and my bun
is lopsided but it has a lot of
character and personality I think it
looks so fabulous I think this is like
one I think this is the beginning of
something really beautiful for you in
the updo category it's my best no I mean
it takes time and practice like I'm
looking at myself in the Monitor and
it's like kind of lopsided and I kind of
look like Cindy luhoo but it just takes
time and it's not doesn't have to be
absolutely perfect yeah I mean don't
worry it's not yeah absolutely perfect
but I really wanted to thank you for the
encouragement and the the wise words
that's what I do I encourage because if
I can just find a way to live my life
without like blowing out my hair every
day not only will it be better for my
hair Health but my mental health as well
yeah and it's always fun to switch it up
I think it looks great I think it's like
a fun New silhouette I think everyone
who's watching is definitely like whoo
whoa whoo right and if in a week's time
I'm like so embarrassed like we'll just
delete the episode and I just I feel
like we always need to find new ways to
spice things up around here and in updo
is one of those maybe on Monday I'll
wear a hat again you never know that's
so true because it it could become you
know quite monotonous if we don't
constantly change up if we don't
constantly change things up I'm changing
things up today wearing a fullon
sweatsuit like not even I mean it's
toast merch so I'm I'm within the
confines of of your of acceptability
yours I'm within my rights but like I'm
just in pain today and I just had to
call it you know well I was in pain
until I just remembered that we secured
for this episode the interview of a
lifetime at the end of this episode so
after the Fast Five and our Southern
Charm recap we are so humbled to be
joined by someone we have been a fan of
for a very long time the one and only my
Povich you are not the father you are
not and he really I mean he's obviously
a fantastic orator because he's the
longest running TV show host in history
but it also translates into him being
like a great guest and just like
answering questions providing context he
really was fabulous guat he was like
very wise and super funny and he's going
into his 23rd season and there's just so
much that goes on like behind the scenes
at my so much that goes on and so you're
going to hear about some of that I mean
I know people are going to be
disappointed because Claudia teased on
her Instagram last night that we had a
very special important guest whose name
starts with an m and obviously all the
mavia stands came out thinking it was
going to be Maverick yeah I'm sorry but
you can't even be disappointed because
it's so iconic that we have Mor on the
show it's so iconic and like Maverick
can come on another time anytime he
wants to he's always welcome he has an
open door policy at the morning toast a
lot of people also thought it was Matt
James but that would that wouldn't be
unexpected cuz we cover the bachelor
yeah but we might have like hyped it up
in that way that's a good guess yeah but
no it's Mory poic and like if you know
me like you know how exciting this was
when I got the email I was like Jackie
we have to do this yeah iconic and he
was so nice so nice so that's at the end
of the episode and I little catch up
with our good friend Mor just to get you
into the weekend and before we get into
everything I just I would be RDH if I
didn't do a little redheads promo
because not only do I love to tell you
about the redheads but this episode is
more pertinent than ever because Claudia
is on the redheads the redheads episode
is available now we are talking all
about her book we are going deep we are
asking specific questions we're getting
clarifications we're getting
Inspirations and if you read the book
and you want to follow up the redheads
book club has the episode for you trbc
trbc it's everything you need and then
we also our regular scheduled redheads
uploads next week so it's just a great
time to be a redhead much like anytime
is a great time to become a redhead I
couldn't agree more and now that you are
a redhead an honorary redhead do you
feel what I'm saying when I say like
it's always a good time always
especially cuz we're coming up on our
Oney year anniversary of being redheads
yeah we have some exciting anniversary
things that's so cute I love that um and
it's like it's been a year still a great
time to become a redhead it's been a
year and it's still a great time oh that
you meant like it's been a year like no
no no I meant it's been a year of
redheads we've done 15 episodes and it's
still a great time to become a redhead
could not agree more it's Never Too Late
ever ever you could give a little more
umph ever ever in your enthusiasm for
trbc I'm sorry I'm just so distracted by
the Friday of it all like I never
thought we would get here I know it's
the end of my oh sorry you it was a dooy
of a week uh not for me no like a doozy
not in a negative way just like it was a
lot of week it was so much week I've
never been so tired in my life but it's
all paid off
because my Memoir girl with an a job is
out and the review are in and they're oh
my god wow kind of Stellar it was a
Freudian drop stop no no because I was
so my my mouth Hit the Floor my jaw
dropped and that's why I dropped the
book when reading the reviews of my book
people are just finding it some people
are saying inspirational so I just
wanted to put that out there in case
you're still kind of nervous like on the
fence I'm going hearo telling you get
off the fence you can do it girl withn
job.com book and I just feel like
sometimes when you read a book like you
just want to talk about it and that's
why the redheads episode is so great
because you just get to like hear your
best friends I'm trying to help you like
promote you I'm agreeing with you you
are very defensive about the redheads
I'm very defensive about my passion
projects that I just don't feel I get
enough enthusiasm from you are you
kidding me I've been sitting here for
the last 10 minutes yeah yeah forever
ever that's not that's not genuine I'm
sorry that you maybe that's something
you should work out in therapy that you
don't accept compliments cuz like I'm
really here cheering you on and you
don't think it's genuine maybe it's
something you should work out in therapy
that you think yeah yeah is a compliment
it is yeah yeah forever ever forever
ever yes that's complimentary and you
cannot change my mind okay well head
over to the redheads for more of this
pretty much um so yes we'll be recapping
Southern Charm we'll be back on our
regular scheduled Bravo recap programing
next week like I said this week was just
a doozy because of my book yeah so
congratulations on a great Pub weekk
your Pub day Vlog is available now on
the patreon yes I put it up was that yes
that was yesterday woo long day woo woo
woo very long day yes I vlogged all of
uh Pub day we went to a couple
bookstores we uh went to GMA we had a
lot of work to do we tasted some
cinnabuns so the Vlog is up at
patreon.com theem morning toast you get
one more episode this month and it's
going to be Jackie O and Ben talking
about our cleanse taking all of your
cleanse questions I'm really excited to
go like find out what he thought about
it I actually like miss my cleanse days
I miss like having a purpose and like
knowing what I was going to be eating or
drinking for the whole day instead of
just like flying by the seat of my pants
and just eating chips all day you have a
purpose what's my purpose host the
morning toast that's true but then like
the day over I just my purpose in terms
of like my health and well Wellness
right now I just am like Free Falling
Free Falling cuz I'm
free Free
Falling that was pretty thank you
Claudia let's get into it thanks Claudia
I put my heart into it thank you L
that's beautiful no when you think when
you said I know thanks Amanda it came
from my heart that's what it was it came
from my heart I haven't watched my
comedy special in so long I'm starting
to like malfunction I need to remember
just me I'm like it came from beautiful
so just go so we can properly quote it
maybe we'll watch it this weekend oh for
sure um but before that before that we
need to get into the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast because most like unlike most of
the other days this week you actually do
need to know these stories like there's
really it's storyful thank God um and
the storyful stories are brought to you
by stamps.com which is so fabulous I
literally used it every day this week to
print labels right from our studio so I
could send out copies of my book to
people who would hopefully post it on
Instagram cuz I'm thirsty as a [__]
let's face it taking trips to the post
office is probably not how you want to
spend your time that's why we recommend
mailing and shipping online at
stamps.com they always allow you to mail
and ship anytime anywhere right from
your computer send letters packages and
pay a lot less with discounted rates
from USPS ups and more with stamp
they've saved businesses thousands of
hours and tons of money because you get
the services of the post office and UPS
all in one place plus big discounts on
mailing and shipping rates simply use
your computer to print official US
postage 24/7 for any letter any package
any class of mail anywhere you want to
send once your mail is ready just
schedule a pickup or drop it off it's
that simple cuz with stamps.com you get
40% off post office rates and up to 62%
off UPS shipping rates not to mention
stamps.com is a fraction of the cost of
those expensive postage me it's a
no-brainer cuz stamps.com saves you time
and money it's no wonder nearly a
million small businesses already use
stamps.com stop wasting time to go to
the post and stop wasting your time
going to the post office and go to
stamps.com instead there is no risk and
with our promo code toast you get a
special offer that includes a 4-week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale there's no long-term commitment or
contracts just go to stamps.com click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in toast that's
stamps.com promo code toast never go to
the post office again love it okay first
story I'm going to sing a song I want
you to guess the story okay just stop
your crying it's a sign of Kardashian
trailer season 20 trailer drops for
final season of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians and and they use an iconic
Harry Style song and they use an iconic
Harry Style song and it is a tearjerker
so I mean it's also like a little
dramatic considering like there will be
a season one of a new season and we're
still going to see them but it's sad
because they're saying goodbye to the
casting crew that they've worked with
who they're very connected to they're
very connected to so it's like they're
saying goodbye to the people who made
the show what it is and they're not
saying goodbye to the audience no
they're saying goodbye to their cast and
crew and good morning to to the
Millennials yeah exactly literally um so
the trailer dropped honestly it looks so
good and EM um but again just dramatic
considering they're coming back via Hulu
but like Kim's crying yeah I mean them
like playing with us like Scott and
Courtney are taking a nap together like
those two it's like I've we've let the
dream die like the Courtney and Scott
fans like we don't exist anymore no and
at this point if they got back together
I would be upset after all they went
through I want so much different for
both of them like Courtney and Travis
Barker like love to see it Scott right
now I'm he's in the dogghouse with the
Amilia H not talk about the new
relationship it's so inappropriate it's
so inappropriate so I would like to see
something else for him something healthy
but I ship them separately I have two
ships for one for each of them and I
ship them on a strictly platonic
co-parenting boat yeah yeah I agree so
the season premieres um 202 in March
18th sorry of 2021 oh that's sooner than
I expected yeah it's on the it's in the
near future but it's still kind of far
away yeah but they love to do that to us
I'm surprised it wasn't for June yeah
yeah no I agree like when they dropped
the trailer I'm like okay it'll be by
the end of the year I can't wait to see
the the show but it's not that far away
um I'm like excited to see it obviously
but I don't really even want it to come
because knowing that we still have one
more season like brings me Solace even
though again they are doing another show
with Hulu who knows what that format's
going to be I have no idea yeah so it's
it's the unknown and this show has been
so good to us and it's really just been
a huge part of our Liv so it will be
Bittersweet to watch yeah it's been a Hu
I mean everyone remembers where they
were when they first started watching
like we I think we both really pride
ourselves on like having watched Keeping
Up with the Kardashians organically from
season 1 and by season 3 like they were
so famous and like they were like ours
cuz like we just love them like they
were sisters and then like everyone
started to love them but like we love
them first yeah I think everyone feels
that way yeah but I also feel like I've
loved them forever except there was like
one time when I was just like really not
feeling them and it was after the Chris
humph and I just could I could not
reconcile my feelings and I just felt
really bad for him um I think everyone
went through a phase during that time
where they were like of confusion like
not knowing what's real what like it it
turned out that like a lot of the
footage that they filmed of Keeping Up
with the Kardashians of Kim like
expressing some of her doubts was filmed
afterwards like it felt like we got
duped and I think a lot of people felt
offensive of Chris Humphries because
even though on the show they made him
look terrible like what they ended up
doing to that man was like disgraceful
yeah so that was just like a hard time
but we we came out of it and we came
through it and I feel feel okay about it
I still feel like Kim and Chris like
maybe could have made it work me too but
I do if they weren't living in an
apartment with Courtney and Scott I do
think though that like that period where
a lot of the world kind of was done with
them benefited them greatly like I think
that they needed that sort of reset and
they needed to get back to like their
roots of being real like they got so
caught up in this like fabulous TV show
that everyone loves and they wanted to
make it so good that they literally
started scripting it and it was so
disappointing and I think that a lot of
people expressing their disappoint
reset them completely and they went back
to like their roots of really organic
filming and not taking you know all of
this for granted so of course you know
that's honestly one of the morals of the
stories in my book it's like everything
really happens for a reason but jce for
Chris offre yes of course okay next
story I don't know if you read this
article but Katherine higel is coming
out of the woodwork she's got a new show
on Netflix and she sat down with the
Washington Post for an in-depth
interview she's needed one of those
mentioning it all oh wow she has needed
one of those for a while yes as we know
Katherine higel was our ROM Kong Queen
for so many years then it like came out
that she was quote difficult to work
with she had said some things that upset
some people and then the whole emy's
thing the emy's thing where okay so she
won an Emmy for her character on Gray's
Anatomy and then the following year she
didn't go to the award show she said
quote I did not feel that I was given
the material this season to Warrant an
Emmy nomination and in an effort to
maintain the Integrity of the academy
organization I withdrew my name from
contention that's an insane Ane [__]
narcissist like that's just the craziest
thing to say and such a slap in the face
to like shond d Rimes and the writers of
Grey's Anatomy yeah so after that like
no one she was done she was done I think
like people didn't want to work with her
and I guess audiences sort of turned on
her cuz some of her movies didn't really
perform well but it's really crazy now
if you read this Washington Post article
it's like the things that she said then
like it was just a few things that made
her quote difficult like if that
happened today she would be probably
celebrated for standing up for herself
she also said that the movie Knocked Up
was like a little um I I don't know the
exact word a little sexist something
like that which is like that's a fair
assessment a CR you could be critical of
art yeah so I think a lot of people took
it as she was ungrateful for her
celebrity I didn't think that but to me
the the emy's thing was like the one
thing that she did that was like so nuts
and like so rude to like all the people
who work so hard and like so celebrity
like I withdrew my name from contention
like that's just so obnoxious put me in
coach kind of hysterical I don't even
remember that part happening I just
remember like she just got this
reputation for being a diva hard to work
with and ungrateful for the opport for
like the roles that she had had no I
know about all this now but when I
experienced it she was on my she was in
the movie theaters every weekend like
with a new movie new movie new movie and
then poof she was gone like that's how I
recall it and then she resurface when I
just started to do a little research I'm
like whatever happened to Katherine
higel and she like lived this fabulous
life she got me married to the lead
singer from Lady antab bellum's brother
yes who came on the morning breath and
was so lovely he's a musician himself
his name is Josh Kelly and he's also
quoted in the article talking about his
Katie oh that's cute and then they moved
to Utah like the best life ever the end
of the article is hysterical cuz it was
like I guess everyone calls her Katie we
call her Katherine and the interviewer
was like now that you know you're moving
forward do you want people to call you
Katie or Katherine like an hathway you
know wants to be called Annie and she
was like you can call me anything just
don't call me difficult that's funny
yeah actually I would this article
that's very interesting it's really
really good so she talks about like sort
of also the mental health Journey that
she went on like and a lot of the
anxiety that she lived with after all of
this had happened and the things that
she um like going to therapy and things
that she did to sort of overcome it but
now she is in a new show on Netflix
called um it's based on a book by
Kristen Hannah Firefly Lane and it's
about like friendship between two women
she plays a TV show host and it's like
over the course of 20 years and Kristen
Hera is a great author and she wrote
Nightingale which is a great book and so
um I feel like this has a m like here
all the makings of a great show I am
here for the comeback of Katherine Hegel
I've always been interested by her I
love her marriage I love the fact that
she lives in Utah and I will be her
Champion I will watch her show I'm here
for it also our King James Marsden is
also quoted in the article where he
talks about cuz they're good friends say
he's in the the TV show no no no they're
good friends and he just is always like
she's always been so opinionated and so
um and like ambitious and driven and
like to him hearing her say those things
it wasn't it wasn't crazy to him no and
it also like but not in a negative way
it's just like the way it came off to
everybody who didn't know her sounded so
much worse of course and by the way it's
worth mentioning that if Katherine Hegel
was a man nobody would have thought you
was difficult they would be like good
for him for having Artistic integrity
right right so the whole thing the whole
Arc of her career is really interesting
and I'm glad to see her coming back to
the screen how did what movie was James
Marsen in with 27 Dresses oh right right
and that's actually like probably one of
my least favorite Katherine hiel movies
yeah oh my God it's Life as we know it
so good it's one of my favorite kathern
higel movies it's so good and who's the
girl in win a date with Chad Hamilton is
that Katherine higel no it's like a
random girl right she never like became
yeah yeah um such a good movie and now
I'm looking at her yeah let's go through
she did that terrible one with Gerard
Butler that was the beginning of ugly
truth I think that one did okay I think
that's a good one and that wasn't my
favorite one no I think one for the
money was the beginning of the end
that's what they said um what else she
was just like a cash cow oh she was in
New Year's Eve oh I'm sorry like we just
put so much disrespect on her name her
number one movie of all time wish upon a
star oh from Disney Channel yes yeah was
it Jessica be in that too no oh but that
is the best movie ever I concur you are
you woke up today and you could speak
any language and you decided to speak
facts and I commend you for that cuz
it's a really Brave thing to do to just
own your truth and you're right you're
right yeah um what other movies this
movie Unforgettable which I think was
sort of a not great One Life as we know
it obviously Killers knocked up big
wedding home sweet Hell she's been in a
lot of movies she's been acting since
she was a teen was she in a thriller I
think that's Unforgettable okay I have
to tell you a story about that movie so
back before I was a disgraced Queen I
did a partnership with the movie studio
for that movie and it was actually
really cool cuz I got to go to an
advanced screening and you would never
know but like these huge movie studios
that have offices in New York they have
these like sick theaters in these
high-rise buildings that are like So
Glamorous they look like like uh what
was the show we were just watching um oh
my God I keep think I keep thinking I
watched the movie Evelyn Hugo because
it's just like in my brain but you know
those old movies where like the movie
execs in the 50s are like smoking cigars
in these like sexy theaters that's like
where I was and it was so cool and this
oh you know what that reminds me of the
show Hollywood yes that too so I went to
one of those fabulous places to get an
early screening of this movie
Unforgettable which was like meant to be
like a thriller and I was in this
theater with all these critics like
legit critics who were like reviewing
the movie for their Publications and
people were like hysterical laughing and
it wasn't a comedy it was like so cringy
bad and I think that was her first
attempt at a comeback because that was
like maybe four years ago and now I
think this Netflix film and this
Washington Post article are better I
wonder why she chose the Washington Post
like she could have gone anywhere yeah
and like print is not like I always feel
like when people are on a Redemption
tour like they should go on Long format
like Howard Stern you know somewhere
they they can explain themselves well I
think this this was good this worked out
I don't know what her reasoning for it
was but it's good mhm yeah um okay are
you ready for our next story yeah Army
hammers stranged wife Elizabeth Chambers
breaks silence which is really an
overstatement on the on Instagram
comment she left an Instagram comment on
ongoing controversy but the story is
really interesting because it was on a
post that um sorry on a post talking
about how Timothy shalamay and the
director of call me by your name are
working together on a project about
cannibalism which is just so weird and
like was it were they working on it you
know a month ago I I don't know I'm sure
that they were you know it's like when
it rains it pours but I just feel like
given everything that's happened maybe
they should stop the work on the project
no I think that's definitely something
worth pursuing you know the stopping of
the project right so it's a uh the story
follows a woman who's on a CrossCountry
trip As She searches for the father
she's never met in an attempt to
understand why she is the urge to kill
and eat the people that love her like
I'm not a movie critic or a film buff by
any means but I just don't think that
this is a movie that needs to be made
it's not a it's not a story wortht
telling no and so Elizabeth Chambers
commented on just Jared's post about
that saying no words and that's her
quote breaking her silence on the
situation The Washington Post needs to
do an article interview with Elizabeth
Chambers like I need to know what she
knows yeah there's so much mystery in
this Army Hammer Story and there's so
much weirdness and I just want to know
like Elizabeth Chambers was married to
him four years like I need to know what
she knows yeah I'm sure she knows a lot
she is a mouthful yeah if you want to
come on the Elizabeth Chambers we would
glad gladly have you yeah so I just
think we should rethink that movie if
we're just if we're talking yeah I think
that's probably like the wise business
decision yeah are you ready for our next
story Little happy couple news is it the
happy couple news that hcn brought to
you by Beachbody that's exactly what it
is because when you see these two
together you're going to want a
Beachbody fabulous it's a new year and
our resolution is to get better in
better shape we like to work out but we
just feel like nothing ever actually
delivers results Beachbody on demand
offers offers over, 1500 atome workouts
plus nutrition plans so no matter what
your goals are they have a program that
will help you build and keep healthy
habits and Beachbody has a history of
success this is the company behind P90X
insanity and 21-day fix now check out
some of beachbody's newest programs like
muscle burns fat and 80-day Obsession
you can get motivated by their super
trainers like Tony Horton Jill Freeman
and Autumn Cal breze their beach body is
ideal for all Fitness levels including
bodybuilding weight training cardio yoga
and dance workouts they even have
workout calendars and progress trackers
they've trained millions of people on
how to lose weight burn calories and get
totally
ripped you can do workouts just as short
as 10 minutes and it doesn't require any
extra equipment because if you live in a
small New York City Apartment like
ourselves extra equipment is just not
something you know we have the it's out
of our vocabulary right um and you can
access it anywhere any time you can view
all the workouts on your computer Smart
TV tablet smartphone Roku Apple TV
chomecast and more so you have
absolutely no excuse for not getting
your workouts in and it's the best deal
in Fitness because listeners of the
morning toast can try it absolutely free
in quarantine I know Jackie's been
really living for the beach body on
demand um and now that you have your new
apartment like your second bedrooms
really turning into like a little home I
mean a little home it's a home gym SL
office and you use Apple TV right is it
easy to yes it's so easy to sync up so
2020 is now behind us and the New Year
means it's time to get in shape to get a
special free trial no obligation
membership text toast to 303030 you'll
get full access to the entire platform
all the workouts nutritional information
and support absolutely free just text
toast to
303030 love it okay new happy couple
news ex Bachelor Nick viall and Natalie
Joy our Instagram official I feel like
Nick vile is like the world's most was
the world's like most eligible bachor
and now it seems as though he's off the
market Nick V appeared to confirm his
relationship status on Wednesday by
posting a video with rumored girlfriend
Natalie Joy the former Bachelor star
reposted a clip from her to his
Instagram story which showed him playing
a virtual reality game and looking cozy
with his gpow yeah I mean if you're like
an internet sleuth like we knew this a
while ago yeah but it the story is that
like they are they've gone public
they're confirming that they are in a
relationship and I think that's really
sweet I I I want love and um forever for
Nick vile and so I support his
relationship I agree with you that over
the last like a couple years Nick vile
has become like one of the most eligible
bachelors not only is he like AR like
just you can't argue like he's very
handsome um he's his podcast is super
successful he's has a woke mind and he
respects women he's very intellectual
yeah that's the word thank you very
intellectual and I was actually thinking
about this the other day I think the Arc
of Nick vile is not spoken about enough
like a beautiful thing to Behold a lot
of people forget like how hated he was
people said he was misogynist for
calling out Andy Dorfman on mental law
saying why did you have sex with me oh
sorry why did you make love to me and he
was like a villain yeah and then when he
went on Caitlyn season he was the
villain again because like he was
threatening her love with Shawn and he
really like came so far from that to
then being The Bachelor to now being
like such a respected former reality TV
star and we absolutely love to see it
yeah I want to know the pr strategy
behind it cuz I could use some of that
good pre like PR it's pretty genius like
and I don't think it was like a strategy
I think it happened it's like truly
organic I think like the the evolution
of his brand like closely follows just
the evolution of himself yeah which is
all you can hope for right because it's
so genuine so genuine love that for him
so for him to be at like this love stop
on the tour I'd love to see it beautiful
he just bought a house like living the
life happy for him Liv living the life
so happy for them our fifth and Final
story is a little Biz news is it the
stocks it's the stocks it's actually
some big [__] Biz news you guys like
the bizor is a calamate and ever since
yesterday I have educated myself I have
educated myself and I feel as though I
angry I can do a decent job of
explaining the situation for people who
like need it in layman's terms okay so
and I think we got what we said
yesterday we were we were correct but we
we hadn't gotten to the second half of
the story which is the corruption the
corrupt of it all corruption The Citadel
of it all the Robin Hood Citadel owns
Robin Hood that was the big exposure the
craziness okay they're protect Robin
Hood claims to be for the average Trader
to democratize the stock market yeah
like you don't have to work on Wall
Street like this is the platform for
everyone and here they are yesterday I
literally opened the app in the morning
couldn't trade couldn't do anything I've
been on there for a while like not that
much money but still they decided to
protect Big Wall Street guys help them
cut their losses because they got
Exposed on Reddit and now the everyday
Trader who they claimed to be for isn't
screwed screwed thank you screwed so
it's just not fair they just Chang the
rules the rules have been changed when
it's in in the middle like in the middle
of a Monumental moment for the little
guy for the little guy and like the
stock market I don't I'll never claim to
understand the stock market I took econ
and it was literally like the least
sense ever was made in the entire class
but what I do know is that there are
rules and the rules cannot be broken and
the rules they can be well right usually
as of yesterday the rules can officially
be broken can greatly benefit you or be
your downfall but the rules have always
stayed the same until yesterday right
okay so that some days like we just
decided that we don't want to trade
today like so here's what happened like
with the redditors and everything so
GameStop which is a very sort of archaic
it's not a good stock yeah it wasn't a
good stock and a a hedge fund realized
that they were probably not going to do
well so they bet against GameStop it's
called shorting it but in like if you're
betting it's like betting that someone's
going to lose you know right and these
hedge funds have so much data and
yesterday it was actually Rel it was
found out that not only does Robin Hood
is owned by like major whatever they
also sell your data to hedge funds so
they're really like supporting the big
guys on really sick but up until
yesterday like Robin Hood we used to do
ads for them on the show so it's like
that's how I found out about it right so
like if you are just a person and you
want to buy and sell some stocks Robin
Hood is the app for you if you're making
trades without going through a broker if
you're not part of a hedge fund like you
just use an app like [__] has a broker
you just use an app like head like Robin
Hood yeah and Robin Hood is named after
Robin Hood who would steal from the rich
and give to the poor and yesterday they
did the exact opposite the iron it's
just so bunch people on a subreddit
Channel Wall Street bets and it's like a
popular Reddit before all this they had
like 2 million subscribers now they have
literally like 8 million because they
accurately predicted a short right so
they saw that this hedge fund took this
position betting against GameStop for
like billions of dollars billions of
dollars so they said let's all get
together buy up GameStop stock to go up
to go up to sort of expose the hedge
fund and not expose them like in the way
that we talk about celebrities but like
expose their weakness like their money
like they would right no so like
basically the the hedge fund puts so
much money into gamestock betting that
it will lose so all these people on
Reddit were like if we all buy it the
stock will go up and the Wall Street
guys will literally have made an
incorrect analysis and will lose
billions of dollars right and that's
what started to happen yesterday the
GameStop stock went up over 400% they
did it with Nokia and AMC Theaters yes
and the hedge fund that had waged this
short bet was losing billions of dollars
more than they even have in their fund
just love to see it so another fund W
Citadel wound up covering their oh
interesting yeah giving them the money
so that they didn't go Belly Up and
that's where citadel's involvement comes
in that's interesting did I make up that
Citadel owns Ben told me that citel own
but I also haven't been online this
morning no Ben told me that yesterday
so game stops up 400% the hedge funds
are losing billions of dollars the
little people on Reddit who came
together to buy the stock are making a
lot of money like doubling tripling
quadrupling their initial investment and
then Robin Hood yesterday decided that
you they stopped any trading of these
stocks so if you could not buy more
GameStop if you own the stock you could
only sell it in an effort to sort of um
balance B like tip the scales back and
it cover these big hedge funds that are
losing billions of dollars the real
moral of the story here is a bunch of
people on Reddit outsmarted Wall Street
and you just love to see it and Wall
Street they beat them at their own game
fair and square but they didn't incur
the losses that they should have and
that's not fair no that's not fair the
fact that Robin Hood changed the rules
is protecting like there's going to be
major class action lawsuits like people
should be going to jail for this I could
by the way I could be I I bought AMC
stock and yesterday they would not let
me sell or buy more like I'm involved in
the lawsuit on Robin Hood and I would
like my money it is so crazy what they
did in terms of not letting people buy
more GameStop in order to protect these
billion dooll companies from people who
are like the little people if we don't
have a free market we don't have
anything you guys it's so corrupt the
corruption runs so deep and like I'm
living for like everyone on all spec
like people who are on both sides of the
political aisle people who have
different opinions on everything like
everyone is agreeing how [__] up this
is It's like a great moment of unity for
us no but it's also like a scary moment
of oh of freedoms being clamped down no
I mean I couldn't agree with you more my
freedoms definitely feel like they're
being clammed you you look like they're
being clammed that's why my hair is up
so as of today Robin Hood is like
allowing some trading of GameStop but
going ja the damage is done like so
corrupt so illegal so unfair there and I
just it was it was really crazy thing to
to watch unfold I bought Doge what's
Doge I don't know everyone's talking
about it so I bought it Ben told me to
do it so oh you know let me check right
now cuz it's a crypto and it was like
super low I don't [__] with the stock
market I'm like starting to now I and
now I have a good reason not to and now
I'm starting to regret it but so okay
doge is a crypto so it's like really
really
small crypto is interesting okay I made
$25 and I bought it this morning M like
that's pretty good so it's 05 and people
are saying it's going to go to like $20
or something which would be crazy ooh
what if we oh my God you guys what if we
get the toasters together to go against
a short that hedge fund has hedge their
bet hedge it up and the power of the
toasters and then everyone be like The
Toasters beat Wall Street hedge it up so
yeah do your cat is where is at oh my
God if we could save one
stock what would it be
like which shock would we choose yeah
yeah yeah like one come like because
also what's so upset like so morally
corrupt about this is that they are
betting that GameStop would fail which
is a brick and mortar store that's
obviously not doing well because of the
pandemic and like Wall Street is going
to would have made billions of dollars
off of the fa like the very sad failure
that's really true of a store that's
been around for a long time I forgot
about that Ben it has like a really
sentimental life but a lot of young um
people have memories of like going into
GameStop and Ben like like cries every
time he talks about to GameStop because
it was like it's childhood well he
should be happy today yeah GameStops
Fortune 500 oh that was the best part
like M that Meme of like GameStop which
was like a shitty stock forever is like
now at evaluation that like apple is at
because so many people are buying it so
like they're sitting at a table with
like a bunch of like legitimate serious
ass companies that they never would have
been at it was honestly a a heroic
ending until it wasn't yeah and I look
forward to the movie that's made about
this so that we could really understand
it but it also can't get made until um
it's until proper actions and
punishments are taken
yeah okay wait let me think maybe what
we call like Wall Street bets which is
like the name of the subreddit that
could be good oh yeah that is or um I
got to get on that
subreddit Robin
Hood I don't know let's think on it yeah
um so let's dive into our TV recap could
be called The Big
Short that's such a good movie what
about the little short yeah or like um I
didn't like that movie oh it's so good I
didn't like it it's cuz that's a really
hard thing to understand I mean it's
similar to stocks but it's also about
like the housing market and the bubble
and even though the movie is so good and
it explains so much I don't like I still
don't fully understand it but I
understand more than I ever would have
if they didn't make a movie about it um
TV recap TV right I forgot about that
first part of the Southern Charm reunion
I just want to say my theory was correct
the reunion is so amazing and I think
really think that the worse a season in
the is the better a reunion is cuz
there's more things to unpack I mean
everyone just came out [__] like on
fire like Craig oh my God chill the [__]
out no but like Craig is my king and
watching The Reunion last night it's
hard because I I really like Madison and
like watching people that I like argue
it hurts you know it really hurts it is
painful to watch because
there's so clearly a double standard in
this group like the way they talk about
Madison like calling her like [__] like
it's disgusting when all of them are are
vile like they all [__] a million girls
all the time celebrities non-
celebrities so when Madison is strategic
with her xmlb player like she's a [__]
but when everyone else does it it's
totally fine like there's such a clear
double standard that it's actually
really frustrating to watch it is but it
does start feel like it's starting to be
called out a little a little bit but
what I was going to say was Craig like
even though I I really like Madison
Craig has been on the show now it's just
him and chep who have been on since
season one and like really if you
rewatch oh and Katherine sorry if you
rewatch everything Craig is right about
everything he really is always like
taking the right side so and I hate to
like use that as a template to be like
so I'm always going to agree with Craig
but I just sometimes when I'm like
unclear I'm like well Craig usually has
an eye for these things yeah I think a
lot of interesting things came out of
this reunion of course the xmlb player
which a lot of people online are saying
is A-Rod but married no but okay so
there's a bunch of things there's a
bunch of things I think that they sort
they were talking about like married men
and I think that they allowed the audio
to sound like they're talking about a
married MLB player because it lessens
like their exposure on A-Rod to A-Rod
and like I do think that they are
worried because like now that southern
charma is being so close like all of
these Bravo Instagram accounts it's like
they keep saying it's A-Rod it's A-Rod
it's A-Rod and like this is going to get
to JLo and I don't think Andy wants to
deal with that but it's really so crazy
but also like I was watching all of
these stories from um some of these
Bravo Instagram accounts of like so
people are saying that it's A-Rod he had
lik some of her photos it looks like
they were in New York City at the same
time and then so so many other people
are coming out with like stories about
you know their friend hooking up with
A-Rod or A-Rod hitting on their friend
and it's
like even if one of these things is true
like the nerve he has the nerve and the
call like how dare you how dare you and
it's like what's so crazy I was thinking
M as I went to sleep last night he like
Jennifer Lopez is like the most perfect
human on the face of the Earth like so
stunning so beautiful so talented like
everything of the sort and it's like
even she she like excuse me Beyonce
right right that I mean if if there's
ever a template for like how literally
like no one is above getting cheated on
like Beyonce No but it's like it's not
even like he's I mean he is cheating on
her but it's like the disrespect that
like no yeah nobody like yeah that's the
thing no like if Beyonce and get cheated
on like women will never get respect
that's what I'm saying yes no it's so
valid I think about that thing with
Beyonce all the time cuz like she's the
most beautiful woman on the planet and I
think many people would argue the most
talented person all around in multiple
categories stunning beautiful smart like
everything of A Sort and she got cheated
on like there's no hope for the rest of
us no it's like and she can't even get
respect in her house in her marriage
yeah no it's disgusting it made me like
really mad reading all that stuff it's
it's like what is JLo doing yeah no it's
shocking I mean what is he doing yeah no
what is he doing what is he doing but
it's like I just I I don't understand so
that was one interesting that came out
that interesting thing that came out of
the readed yes another very very
interesting thing was that Craig's
girlfriend not only hooked up with
Austin but was on love connection and is
being kind of portrayed as this TV star
[__] thirst monster thirst monster yes
I mean it's a hard spot to be in because
like even watching her on the show she
seems so cute and sweet and like sort of
like these things are coincidences maybe
and the thing about Austin like I could
have lived with but to find out she was
on love connection is um really strange
and I I feel like Shep like not like
really liking this girl but not knowing
how to reconcile that yeah 100% we don't
even know her well enough to like really
get a sense of like if it's a
coincidence if it's strategic but I
agreed like it's it's a lot to take in
it's a lot to take in and it's like
extra weird that it was this show love
connection which like never watched and
is wased by Andy and was hosted by Andy
no but like if she had been someone who
had been on The Bachelor like it would
have be different 100% you mean 100%
okay um another thing that I no it's
like she couldn't get on The Bachelor so
she love con she went on the next best
thing yeah another thing I notic about
the reunion that I really have been
coming to this conclusion over the last
few weeks is that like Southern Charm
and the editors like really did Lea
sorry Leva so dirty like because I was
just enjoying her so much last night and
I'm like oh that's because she's not
talking about Catherine and it's like
they just pieced together this entire
season every moment where she was
talking about Catherine and exclusively
use that footage so even though she's
right in what she's saying about
Catherine it's like Leva like get a life
even though she has a life like she's a
kid and multiple restaurants and we saw
none of that so just when I saw her and
Watch What Happens Live and now at the
reunion like talking about other things
other than Catherine it's like this girl
is fabulous and I'm just like I'm
wishing we saw more of that I know it
really is not cool what they did but
also I was loving the conversation cuz I
mentioned on the show that her son they
call him little and I I just think
that's such a cute name and so getting
the explanation that he's actually like
Lamar iiii but usually that's called
trip which I didn't know that either
didn't know that either and now it's
like oh and I think maybe I I had heard
it once but I never thought enough about
it cuz now it's like three triple trip
makes total sense it's so cute it's so
cute but then like the fact that he was
like I'm big Lamar and you're little
Lamar and now he's called little like
like as just someone who loves nicknames
like that just mean meant that just
touched my heart it was a beautiful
origin
story it really really was no I
completely agreed with you I think it's
the cutest nickname ever I think it's
the cutest nickname and I never would
have guessed that her kid's name was
Alfred no no mean either and that like
trip is the third yeah I loved it I
wonder if there are some people who
don't know that like that's what that is
so they name their kid trip yeah know
100% they're like but what is trip short
for in their minds you know I don't
Triple
sack like you know no but I when when
she said that I was like oh my God
that's like when I learned that people
from Mars are called martians like
something that I should have known my
whole life but didn't yeah or that
Rascal wasn't a name right right but it
could be it could be um another big
conversation that was had was kind of
the evolution of Shep yes and I thought
it was incredibly genuine like I'm I'm
always a champion of people like
bettering themselves growing learning
every day and I just loved that
conversation I think he had like a true
self- awareness that he's never had
before yeah and you can really see the
growth you know so I think that's like
where we land on like when people mess
up it's like yes you need to apologize
and but you also need time and space to
grow and and change and I feel like
that's what Shep has done yeah you know
cuz like the way that he reacts to
things like the way that he lives his
life now like he's different than he was
a year ago yeah and that's like that's
growth when I heard that he had you know
had an indiscretion with a woman um I
was like really mad at him I was I was
upset too but I I just thought it was
going to be worse yeah it was a kiss but
still like and that's just so like the
Southern Charm trouble standard and I'm
so glad Leva pointed it out like the
romanticizing of cheating and the
glorification of it like if Madison did
that like oh my God it's just so
hypocritical and even though like
sometimes Madison says and does things
that are so indefensible like at the end
of the day you cannot deny the Inc like
the just hypocrisy in this cast like
it's so crazy and it's so [__] up yeah
um another thing I want to talk about
two things one like forgot Danny beard
was there pretty much the entire time
she spoke and I'm like who is that I'm
like why is she
crying yeah and then the other thing
which I found to be probably the most
interesting conversation was the Cameron
Eubanks of it all yes and there's one
other interesting conversation um about
miss Patricia that I want to talk about
but yes let talk about Cameron so I had
no I knew that it was always a mystery
to us like why she left but I didn't
know it was a mystery to everyone else
like that nobody knows the reason and
this is like the first time on a show
where they're actively talking about
like someone who chose not to be on and
like also like is she coming back next
season I feel like Cameron if she
watches season is so glad not to be a
part of it there's nothing on this
season for her but so for the people who
are friends with her to say like she's
upset she didn't do it like I never
would have gotten that Vibe and I mean I
get really heated and I I fully take
Katherine's side when it comes to like
those rumors because first of all it's
worth mentioning I heard those rumors
like on in stagram on blogs like years
ago they've always been circulating and
everything in Catherine's life has been
put on blast like not by herself but
like her stuff with Thomas her stuff
with the kids custody drugs like
everyone has put every facet of
Catherine's life on blast and she more
than anyone has bled out so hard for the
success of this show and Cameron has
kind of been the one like leading the
charge even when they flash back to
those old clips when cat um no it was
about the pillows when cam was laughing
about like someone saying Craig is going
to retire on pillows like it's just so
mean she was really kind of mean yes I
agree and for a while like she was made
to feel like the moral compass of the
show and now like now knowing all we
know it's actually like so [__] up
everything Cameron did to like a her
fellow female castmate who's like also a
mom like she should have related to her
more on that level and I do know in her
last seasons like she did try and make
amends but like it was honestly so
little so late and it was not nearly
enough and I'm with Katherine like I'm
mad like you have [__] too like let's
[__] talk about it my shit's been
spoken about in the same way that the
people sit on the stage and call Madison
a home wrecker cuz they say she slept
with married men in Charleston which is
like a rumor even if they know it to
they think to be true like they're just
spewing some [__] out that we haven't
seen on the show it's so that's what
we're doing that's what Catherine was
doing also I felt when I was watching
those former Cameron scenes with
Katherine it's like Cameron owed
Katherine this big apology like I'm
sorry for everything and she gave that
to her I feel like we saw it at the last
and she was like really moved and
understood that like she was really on
the wrong side of history and so like
this is what I'm saying about CHF that's
one thing like she apologized and she
meant it but then I would have loved to
see seasons of Cameron supporting
Redemption Cameron supporting Catherine
you know she just bounced yeah and I
like honestly like I I don't respect
that at all no and it's just unfair and
it's like in hindsight watching the
season it's like she makes sense she's
not on the season there's nothing for
her on the season but when they set out
to film the season like it could have
been another Cameron Centric season no
and honestly now more than ever I feel
like
she would fit in on the show Leva
Katherine Madison and now Cameron are
all moms like there's really no reason
for her not to be on the show right and
Leva was a really close friend of hers
which is really weird that they don't
speak anymore I thought that Cameron
like when when I would think about it I
would think that Cameron brought Leva
onto the show like wanted Leva to be on
the show wanted like a great friend for
her and like Ally to have and Leva
contributes lot to show so now knowing
that like Leva being on the show not for
not directly but now not friends because
of it or not directly because of it but
they're just she's on the show now and
they're not friends like I'm sure that
two things have to do with one another
um is really weird completely completely
agree it's very spooky stuff spooky
stuff and then the last thing was
Patricia and I loved what Katherine said
she was Katherine didn't say much on
this particular episode I'm sure her
time will come but the few things that
she did said I just agreed with her she
was like why is this older woman just
sitting around like bashing this young
entrepreneur's business 100% I I was so
glad that and what's so crazy and I'm so
mad at the girls for defending Patricia
because it's like well Madison always
defends Patricia yeah but she could have
kept her mouth shut she really could
have because what Craig said was not a
lie like Craig has always been nice and
respectful towards Patricia Patricia
watched him on HSN and was being rude
talking [__] and turns out saying some
lies saying her pillows are luxury and
his are affordable when hers are $20 and
his are8 he said was the prices of their
and that she is no longer on HSN he just
he chose to speak one language and he
chose facts and and I appreciate that
and so for the girls that like that's
not fair and it's like no the fact are
fair Patricia was speaking like with
judgment in her voice Patricia started
it Craig was sharing facts so like I was
really disappointed in Madison obviously
for defending her and Leva too and I
feel like Patricia has contributed to so
much of this like inj boys club culture
on the show like keeping the status quo
as it is for years putting down
Catherine then only turning around when
like she realized the whole world that
no one was on her side and so to see the
women defend her when like finally
people are realizing what she's all
about was really irksome I completely
agree there's so much Injustice in this
franchise like and it's definitely
better but it's not even close to like
where it needs to be yeah I agree I got
very heated there for a minute I
apologize I always get heated when it
comes to Patricia yeah I mean me too I
literally like dying on this hill from
season one I just that it's weird that
she hangs out with these people and that
she's so mean
and just picks and
chooses in unjust um so that's our
Southern Charm I'm like sure she's
fabulous but at what cost I agree I mean
Austin said it best like it's very sad
like has it has Patricia never been in
love it's always been about money oh my
God Austin that was a shady [__] yeah
so anyways I thought the reunion was so
good and there were also like moments
where I was genuinely smiling and me too
and they all looked all the women looked
stunning Leva looked so beautiful oh my
God yes Catherine's New Look is fabulous
I mean Madison and her um Revenge bod
were just like doing the most wait when
Craig was like I mean Love's kids and
Austin kids like could be models and
Catherine's like what about my kids so
so funny but also like that they're
that's what I love about the show like
they're actually friends and like they
have really good senses of humor and and
that's what makes the show go around
also the fact that like the men are all
growing out their hair was just like an
interesting choice I did not enjoy it
when they flashback to like Shep being a
dick to Madison like two seasons ago he
looked so much more handsome I'm like
you've got to cut your hair I know it
was like really jarring yeah they're
like getting old and like getting
comfortable no I think Craig's hair I
think he flat ironed it like it was so
it was very like you know emo Bieber
like curtain bangs like sidebangs yeah
but that's the thing about like I'm sure
he's just going to cut it for next
season so it's not really a big deal I
think that would be best yeah
um that's the Southern Charm recap we're
really excited for this Mory poic
interview enjoy it Relish in it take
Mor's wide wise words of wisdom take
them to heart
and just don't take it for granted and
have a great weekend after because you
want to hear from us after myy love you
guys so much have a great day if you're
watching on YouTube Mory is on the
podcast app so head over there and we
love you bye have a great
weekend